just a moment to truly relax into the
Christ that is inside
already and to truly
feel where one should still
repent where one should still
forgive where one should still
heal diving into all of those
fearlessly and
watching how those contractions
expand more and more into the kingdom of
the
father and feeling more and
more of the father as the
totality as the father's wrath against
Injustice as the father's expansion of
all of the planets contraction s of all
of its traumas to be
healed for separation to no longer be
seen for innocent children women men to
all be abundant and prosperous with
basic needs and free energy in the new
Earth letting God's will Channel through
the body through the body for that new
world getting completely out of the way
through crucifixion completely out of
the way for God's will to Shepherd the
new
world a world without
corruption a world without
greed a world without hoarding without
without
selfishness without ego without
malevolence without violence without
war with such radical
abundance in energy and
prosperity that even the need for money
is
obsoleted every
day all waking up free the entire
totality of your body called Earth
waking up
free creating celebrating
playing every day in perfect harmony
with nature and
Technology the kingdom of God is
here the Kingdom of Heaven is
here
Paradise is
here through
Christ it shall
be do not pretend like you know better
than
Christ because you
don't so take the
portal It's Your Divine Birthright take
the
portal take the
crucifixion take the rebirth
and let God's will Shepherd the new
world and so it
is
amen and so it